the small business administration
released a bunch of data about the
businesses
that received ppp money and eidl
loans through the coronavirus stimulus
that was done some months ago
and immediately a very troubling pattern
was revealed
in which donald trump's own businesses
and his son-in-law jared kushner's own
businesses benefited hugely
from these funds listen to some of what
we've learned
25 ppp loans worth more than
3.6 million dollars were given to
businesses with addresses at trump and
kushner
real estate properties paying rent to
trump and kushner so
that's indirect trump and kushner
benefited
from rent money that was obtained by
their tenants
from ppp that's number one number two
15 of those properties self-reported
that they only kept one job
zero jobs or simply didn't report
jobs retained thanks to that money loans
to trump and kushner properties
include a two million dollar loan to the
triumph restaurant corporation located
inside trump hotel and tower in new york
city
they reported that the money did not go
to keeping any jobs
and then they closed down i'll take the
money
then i'll close and i'll keep the money
a company called lb city incorporated
which is located at kushner's bungalow
hotel in jersey
received the loan for half a million
bucks and used that to keep some jobs
two tenants at 725 fifth avenue which is
trump tower received more than a hundred
thousand dollars and kept only
three jobs three jobs total four tenants
at the kushner owned
in the infamous six six six five six six
six fifth avenue
in manhattan received more than two
hundred thousand dollars and kept only
six jobs and this entire thing has ended
up being
a major cash grab for trump and kushner
directly and
indirectly over 100 loans we also
learned
were made to companies where no business
name was listed in the field where
you're supposed to put in your business
name to get the money
they either put in uh nothing or
like it listed a phone number or a date
like that could be a clerical error but
it also might not be i go and ask for a
loan and they say oh
uh what what's the business name oh the
business name is june 17th
oh sure here have some money so first of
all
none of this should come as a shock
obviously trump and his family
were going to take advantage of this
money in any way that they could
but meanwhile remember that we're
supposed to believe we can't afford
health care
we can't afford uh to make sure nobody
goes hungry
we can't afford to forgive student loan
debt we can't even afford a 15
an hour minimum wage we can't do
mortgage and rent relief
during coronavirus but look at all of
this money that is just flying around
much of which
should not be remember that right after
the stimulus was approved donald trump
removed
the person in charge of oversight of
stimulus funds
so it was obvious that they were going
to do this from day one
trump and kushner grifted the hell out
of the coronavirus
stimulus money but we're supposed to
believe joe biden is the socialist and
that's where you know when you come
around
the truth really doesn't matter when you
have
nearly half the country so radicalized
by ideas like trust fox news and joe
biden
is a socialist and trump will fix all of
your problems
that it doesn't matter what the facts on
the ground are and
understand the contrast here for example
um i mean listen i've talked i've told
the story before i'll
tell it again i my uh lawyer and
accountant
contacted me when the stimulus stuff was
was announced and said
you you can get money you can get money
and you won't have to pay it back like
you could just take money
and at the time i mean maybe i did the
wrong maybe i'm the naive one
but at the time i said listen uh we've
lost some ad revenue but i've gone to
the audience and i've said listen we
we need your support i get that a lot of
people are in tough financial situations
but get a membership pay five bucks a
month if you can afford it
and enough people did where i said to
our lawyer and accountant
let's not do it it just doesn't feel
right like i don't feel like we're
really struggling in the way that some
of these small businesses that are
physical businesses rather than virtual
businesses
they're struggling really badly it feels
as though any dollar i take
might be a dollar i'm taking away from
somebody else uh
and meanwhile uh you have companies
like the ones that trump and kushner run
and rent to
taking money money money closing in some
cases and not having to pay the money
back
and listen maybe i should have taken it
right i mean i've spoken on live streams
about how
in the last month we've had hundreds and
hundreds of people have to cancel
memberships because they've lost jobs
or didn't get jobs back or had hours cut
because of what's going on
maybe i should have taken the money but
then that would make me as bad as them
wouldn't it
uh so it's a really um it it
there's a lot of ambiguity but it
certainly didn't
feel like this money was intended for me
it sure as hell should not have been
intended for billionaires who can float
their businesses on their own but are
choosing not to
disgusting stuff and i can only imagine
i can only imagine how much more we're
going to learn about this
in the next few weeks as we continue to
comb through the data
let's take a quick break we'll be back
after this much more to discuss
on this very important day the uk
approving a coronavirus vaccine for
emergency use